we now look at an application of the
Bayes rule that involves a continuous
unknown random variable which we try to
estimate based on a discrete measurement
our model will be as follows
we observe the discrete random variable
K which is Bernoulli so it can take two
values 1 or 0 and it takes those values
with probabilities Y and 1 minus y
respectively
this is our model of K the catch is that
the value of y is not known and it is
modeled as a random variable by itself
you can think of a situation where we
are dealing with single coin flip we
observe the outcome of the coin flip but
the coin is biased the probability of
heads is some unknown number Y and we
try to infer or say something about the
bias of the coin on the basis of the
observation that we have made so what we
assume about this Y or the bias of the
coin if we know nothing about this
random variable we might as well model
it as a uniform random variable on the
unit interval and the question now is
given that we made one observation and
the outcome was 1 what can we say about
the probability distribution of Y given
this particular information so the
question that we're asking is what we
can tell about the density of Y given
that the value of 1 has been observed
the way to approach this problem is by
using a version of the Bayes rule we
want to calculate this quantity for the
special case where K is equal to 1 so
let us calculate the various pieces on
the right hand side of this equation the
first piece is the density of Y this is
the prior density before we obtain any
mesh
and since the random variable is uniform
this is equal to 1 for y in the unit
interval and of course it is 0 otherwise
the next piece that we need is the
distribution of K given the value of y
well given Y K takes the value of 1 with
probability equal to Y so the
probability of 1 if we're told the value
of Y is just Y itself Y is the bias of
the coin that we're dealing with the
next term that we need is the
denominator we will use this formula it
is the integral of the density of Y
which is equal to 1 and it is equal to 1
only on the range from 0 to 1 times this
probability that K takes value a certain
value in this case we're dealing with a
value of 1 so here we're going to put 1
instead of K and therefore we're dealing
with this expression here which is just
Y and we integrate it over Y's so this
is y squared over 2 evaluated at 0 & 1
which gives us 1/2 so this is the
unconditional probability that K is
equal to 1 if we know nothing about Y by
symmetry higher biases or equally likely
as lower biases so we should expect that
it's equally likely to give us a 1 as it
is to give us a 0 now we have in our
hands all the pieces that go into this
particular formula and we can go ahead
with the final calculation so in the
numerator we have 1 times this term
evaluated at k equal to 1 which is equal
to Y and then in the denominator we have
a term that
nuh to 1/2 so the final answer is to why
over what range of Y's is this correct
well only for those Y's that are
possible so this is for wise in the unit
interval if we are to plot this PDF it
has this shape this is a plot of the PDF
of Y given that the random variable K
takes on the value of 1 initially we
started with a uniform for y so all
values of Y were equally likely
but once we observed an outcome of 1
this tells us that perhaps Y is on the
higher side on the higher end rather
than the lower end so after we obtain
our observation the random variable Y
has this distribution with higher values
being more likely than lower values this
example is the prototype of situations
where we want to estimate a continuous
random variable based on discrete
measurements essentially it is the same
as trying to estimate the bias of a coin
based on a single measurement of the
result of a coin flip as you can imagine
there are generalizations in which we
observe multiple coin flips and this is
an example that we will see later on in
this class